Search engines are really useful.
To use them to solve problems like this, we need to know more about to search for.
We'll try searching for union and well, we get a lot of stuff that's not very useful.
We can see that the Philadelphia Union lost its last game.
We can learn about credit unions and Union College--that's not going to work very well.
We could try the same search on a different search engine, put DuckDuckGo,
and it's a little more helpful maybe.
It does give us computer science as one of the choices for unions but what it gives us under that
is not too helpful for what we're looking for.
We could also try my personal favorite search engine--Search With PETER.info,
and if we search there let's see what we find--world domination plans,
and then we find the discussions on the Udacity forum about this very question.
This is kind of an unusual result and probably not what we should normally be doing.
What we really should be doing is thinking of better things to search for.
Instead of searching for union, let's add Python to our search.
Let's search for Python in union and now we start already to get very interesting results.
We didn't need to think too hard about what to search for.
Searching for Python and the thing we want to do on Python actually turns out
quite a lot of useful information, and we can see the second hit here
is actually doing exactly what we want or something very close to it--
it's how to find the intersection in union of two list in Python, and if we cook on that,
we can see some code and it actually has code for doing union.
One thing we might do would just be to copy that code and I'm going to discourage you
from doing that but let's try that first.
We found this code and this doesn't do quite what we wanted in the question
but what I'm going to ask you to do for the quiz is to take this code
and turn it into something that does what you want.
Let's assume that you did this--you search for how to union two list in Python
and you came up with this code and let's assume that if you have only taken CS101
that there's lots of things in here that might be a little strange to you--having this string here.
We haven't used docstrings in CS101, so that looks a little strange.
We haven't seen sets and we've seen lists but we haven't seen anything quite like this.
There's a lot of mysterious stuff in this code, but let's assume it does what is says it does
and your question is--could you use this to solve the original problem.
Your goal is to implement a union function that behaves as specified in the original question--
which is that modifies the first input to become the union.
So after calling union passing in a and b, instead of getting a result which is the union of the two list
as this code does, what you want to do is modify the value of a to contain the union of a and b.
And I should add a note here that says it's a pretty silly thing to do, but see if you can do it anyway.